karl rove former deputy chief of staff
to president george w bush and a fox
news contributor carl great to have you
with us uh this afternoon um you know
let's start by looking back at this
tweet that then candidate joe biden put
out there speaking of tweets as jen saki
just was so on february the 1st 2020 we
all remember we began the lockdowns in
the middle of march right so it says
joe biden wrote trump further diminished
the u.s in the eyes of the world by
extra expanding his travel ban this new
quote african ban is designed to make it
harder for black and brown people to
immigrate to the united states it's a
disgrace and we cannot let him succeed
your thoughts on this
well not only did he say that but he
also had his future running mate kamala
harris also blasted it as a racist as
did speaker of the house nancy pelosi so
politicizing it a pandemic and just for
political advantage in a presidential
campaign may turn out to bite you and
it's certainly biting a big time here
president trump was a bigot for having a
travel ban extended to south to africa
now president biden is in a position of
having uh put a travel ban from africa
so
he he's he's he's
due every bit of criticism for being a
hypocrite on this it's a sign of how bad
it was last year and how there's going
to be an overhang from having
politicized uh the covet for for
advantage in a presidential campaign
yeah uh that's also go ahead go ahead
carl
well
also the
this is gotta i just returned from south
africa i was in
africa through the middle of dec of
november
and uh
you know they were very grateful for i
happened to be staying at a camp uh in
outside of kruger national park with a
guy who was the head of the south
african tourism association and had
gotten them taken off the british red
list which prohibited travel from the uk
to south africa and to meet with these
people who had been hit by coveted uh
the camps have been shut down they lost
their livelihood for a year they were
enthusiastic about having visitors come
back to their country and now
for they're going to be penalized for
their transparency in revealing this and
i feel sorry for them
um you know with regard to how americans
perceive
this president's handling of kovat
because really this that was one of the
strongest uh things that that joe biden
ran on was that he would handle covet
better than the previous president
president trump did but you know when
you look at the number of deaths there's
actually more deaths in 2021 413 000 uh
compared with 362 000 in
uh 2020 and we experienced it for almost
the entire year in 2020 disapproval
approval ratings for handling of covid
back in may this president had a
64 approval rating on covid now he's
down to 48
uh a bit underwater on that so how does
that impact this presidency carl
well it impacts it a lot is overall
approval rate is in 43 people think he's
doing a lousy job in the economy they
don't think he's doing any kind of a job
on uniting the country and now they're
beginning to think that he's doing a
so-so job on fighting covid
and those were the three big pillars of
his campaign elect me because the guy in
the office today is screwing up on covid
i'll return i'll return our politics to
to uh bipartisanship and i will and
things will be normal and i'll do a
better job on the economy than this guy
does and the president is under water on
two out of three and he is not in good
shape on on the third one coveted think
about that he has lost basically about
uh a third of the people who approved of
him earlier this year on covid now
disapprove of him that's a pretty
significant drop so even while his
number is higher on cova than it is
among his overall approval rating it it
his failure to deliver on covet is
what's helping pull that number down
along with the economy there's a lot of
questions i mean nobody thought that it
was going to be around as long as it has
throughout the course of this year we
have the vaccines a lot of questions
about the booster rollout and now this
travel ban roll out and whether or not
those were well timed but he says
lockdowns are off the table and that was
a you know he was very much in favor of
the lockdowns for a long time
now he has changed his tune watch this
i'll be putting forward a detailed
strategy outlining how we're going to
fight covet this winter
not with shutdowns or lockdowns
but with more widespread vaccinations
boosters testing and more
quick final thought there carl
well he promised us we'd be all
vaccinated by the fourth of july and
this thing would be in the rearview
mirror over-promising and
under-delivering is a big problem for
any politician it's a big one for this
president karl rove thanks says always
good to see you carl
i'm steve ducey i'm brian killman and
i'm ainsley earhardt and click here to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis